hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
so we seem to have
as so often a bunch of saved up
questions here
uh but i'm happy to try and
address anything about science
technology etc
all right we have a question here from
smart
do you think it's possible to time
travel for real
you know time travel is one of these
things that people
uh kind of
talk about i don't know when the first
time when people really started talking
about time travel was i kind of think
the hd wells time travel
uh
time machine book from like the late
very late 1800s might have been the
first time
but
this idea that just like we can travel
around in space
so also we should be able to travel
around in time
is it some level a strange idea it's a
strange idea with respect to our usual
experience of time which is
time you know you can choose where to go
in space you can go somewhere you can go
back from where you went you can move
around wherever you want in space but in
time we seem to inexorably move through
time and there doesn't seem to be any
way to go back now you know we want to
travel to the future we just sort of
freeze ourselves you know every time you
go to sleep you're sort of traveling to
the future in the sense that your
thread of consciousness kind of wakes up
the next day
and you've uh traveled to the future so
to speak but that's not usually what
people mean by time travel what people
usually mean is
we can move back to some time in some
some place in time
and
then
choose to move forward in time choose to
move backward in time at our choice so
to speak
this idea doesn't really make a lot of
sense
the um
in mostly
uh let's talk about what it would mean
if you went back in time
and then time moves forward from where
you went back to so you say i'm going to
change what i did
x number of years ago
and then i'm going to sort of relive
life going forwards
well what will have happened
well if you are in the same universe so
to speak that you were in when you went
quotes back in time
really what has to have happened is you
have to have created this loop where you
have kind of consistency between what
happened back in time and forward in
time
you create kind of so in a sense what
all that time travel could achieve is
having this consistency between what
happened in the past and what happened
in the future and there are many ways
that are that achieve that there are
many things that achieve that for
example if you have a pendulum swinging
back and forth
it's kind of achieving consistency with
what it happens what happens with it in
the future what happens with the past
and that's in a sense the the thing that
when you start thinking about you know
models of space-time for example that
support quotes time travel
the official version of that
in in theory of gravity is what called
closed time-like curves ctcs
and what a closed time-like curve is is
a place where there is sort of this this
connection between the past and the
future that kind of where you are but
what all that's really happening in the
end is that you're creating a forced
consistency between what happens in the
past and what happens in the future it's
not that you in the future can think oh
am i going to go back to the past today
or not
there is a forced consistency of what
happened in the past and what's going to
happen in the future
now
even this idea of the possibility of
closed time like curves
is something that is a weird thing to to
show up in physics although it's not
that
hard to understand what's going on it's
just this consistency between what
happens in the past what happens what's
going to happen in the future
but
there are models of space time where you
get close time-like curves that are the
result of singularities in space-time
and things like this they're kind of
pathologies and the usual theory of of
general relativity the usual theory of
gravity that pathologies that actually
it is usually believed to kind of
permanently hidden from us by event
horizons and so on by the the fact that
even if there is one of these things
there that you can't we can never kind
of know about it from the outside
so
but um
in our
current models of physics
um
the
the general idea of of time travel makes
absolutely no sense because
in our
recent models of physics
the progress of time
is the inexorable doing of computation
the the universe is represented as some
giant network of atoms of space or
whatever and as you progress in time
there's a computation that's going on
where you're progressively rewriting
that network of atoms of space
and it's not the case that you can just
sort of say well i'm going to jump
forwards in time there's this
irreducible computational process that
represents the evolution that the the
progression in time
and again when you if you were to have
something like one of these closed
time-like curves all that does is to say
this thing that happened in the past
must be consistent with this thing
that's happening in the future you don't
get to make sort of the arbitrary choice
of now i'm going to choose to go back to
the past and so on
so i think in the end
i think time travel to is is something
that as such
it's just not a thing that makes any
sense
now you can get kind of the equivalent
of time travel in some ways for example
what does it mean to travel to the
future it in part it's a one-way trip
you know you kind of are sort of
shutting yourself down and only uh
thinking about things again in the
future so your thread of time
has this kind of jump to the future
aspect to it although you don't get to
go back
in terms of the past
one of the things that i find
interesting about sort of the
developments of technology and science
and so on is the extent to which we
learn we can learn more and more about
the past
one might have thought
that
oh well whatever is you know the only
way we know about the past is from books
people wrote about the past
but then there's start to be all these
kind of hints of the past whether it's
from the the genomes of humans where we
can see
from the way that genomes changed and so
on we can see some detail about how some
family relation between humans and the
distant past or some migration of humans
or when we look at some archaeological
site and we realize oh there's this you
know this uh plate that people ate food
off you know six thousand years ago and
there's a little tiny molecular trace of
the food they ate and we can go and look
at the dna of the little you know pieces
of
sheep meat or something that were on
there and uh deduce things about the
about the types of sheep that existed at
that time this ability to go in
and sort of tease out things from
history from these little molecular
traces is something that's interesting
and and i think there'll be more of that
to come
but between dna and these kind of trace
amounts of different materials and so on
and you know exactly how was this uh
this sword used where we can study the
micro details of what happened to the
sword to know this sword was used in
seven battles or something in this way
and that way i think one of the one of
the themes here is
uh solid materials
often have a trace of their history in
something like a gas
there is ultimately a trace of the
history and all the details of how the
molecules are moving around but we are
completely unable in the current state
of technology to know that history and i
don't think that history will be easy to
deduce
for very far going back and into the
past or probably uh at most kind of
minutes i would think
but when it comes to solids
the details of the arrangement of
molecules or atoms on the surface of a
solid
or in the interior of a solid will give
clues about what happened to that solid
in the distant past it's kind of the
ultimate forensic science type of thing
you just look at the every you know you
can imagine kind of unro unraveling
every atom that you see in some surface
and you say well you know how many times
were these keys pressed and in what
order well you start to look at every
little atomic change that was made every
little piece of of you know
kind of grease from fingers and things
like that that went on the keys
and you'll you know be able to start
deducing that if you look sufficiently
carefully at a kind of molecular scale i
think it's kind of the type of thing
which as we get to start doing molecular
scale computing better it's a thing
where i suspect there will be sort of a
a dramatic advance in the ability to
kind of reconstruct the past from sort
of details molecular level details
particularly in solids of of uh that
were left over from the past so we don't
get to do sort of actual time travel but
you know for example one of the things
that's kind of the test case is can we
ever imagine
finding something which told us
what you know ancient babylonian
languages sounded like and obviously we
can get clues from from how they were
you know the mistakes they made in in
you know
stories where somebody thought they
heard one word
but actually it was another word that
was being said you know puns that were
made things like that that gives us some
clues but could there be something where
there's a material object where you know
somebody was was uh
you know
talking to somebody else while they were
making a a
a clay piece of clay on a potter's wheel
or something
and that the vibrations caused some
change in the molecular structure of the
clay as a result of what they were
saying and that's now burnt in and 4 000
years later we can come and decode it
maybe that type of thing will become
possible i think it's quite likely it
will become possible and we'll be able
to do much more sort of detailed
reconstruction of history than we have
in the past i mean i think people are
quite surprised might have been quite
surprised that it's possible to know the
kind of you know we will know
the genealogy of the hundred billion
humans who've lived probably pretty
accurately we know uh you know we'll be
able to gradually start filling in this
network of sort of all of the hundred
billion humans that have lived and uh
that will give us some uh well it will
probably have uh interesting historical
and other implications
but i don't think sort of time travel in
the in the physical get in a time
machine and go and set the uh the gps
uh or gts or something uh to um uh to
say go to this time that's that's just
not going to be impossible i think i
think that's inconsistent with kind of
sort of philosophically inconsistent
it's not a physical impossibility it's
kind of a philosophical impossibility
uh
let's see there's a question here from
asa
has darwinian evolution stopped in
humans
and if so are we descending to
extinction because of
this dysgenics well
gosh um
you know what is darwinian evolution
it's basically
the
the sort of the idea of natural
selection is
the fittest organisms will make more
organisms will have more children
organisms and so the total number of
organisms that you'll get of that type
will gradually increase and if there's
some trait like if you've got a longer
beak you end up being able to catch more
fish
and then you end up having more children
then that trait will gradually end up
being dominant in the population and and
sort of the basic idea is because there
is random mutation and some birds will
have longer beaks some bugs will have
shorter beaks the ones that are shorter
beaks are kind of the losers and they'll
have less children the ones that have
longer beaks are the winners and will
have more children and so on and that is
uh uh and that's kind of the the thing
that leads certain traits to become
dominant and progressively maybe you
know first it's the longer beak then it
turns out it's better to have uh a a
great big tuft of of feathers on your
head or something and so that will end
up becoming a more uh significant trait
and so on it's worth realizing that
evolution can't do everything those
random mutations can only make small
changes the sort of the big dramatic
changes they happen very gradually and
you can see that in the fossil record
things gradually get longer gradually
get shorter sometimes it's like there's
a there's a period of local stability
when there's a definite species that's
formed and it's like this is good uh in
the particular
niche and the particular place in the
world and et cetera with the other
species that are around this is a good
scheme we'll just stick this way for 10
million years or whatever it is and then
maybe something changes in the world or
something changes in the configuration
of other species or just there's a rare
mutation that figures out some great
thing that ends up being more being a
better solution that leads the organism
to have more children and so on
so what's happened with humans
well
it's a complicated story because
a lot of our technology and and uh
ways of life
have separated the purely biological
what's fitter what's not fitter
in terms of what would be kind of the
the raw biology it's now sort of
co-evolving with aspects of uh
of our technology and our societies and
things like this
and you know if you have a a uh
a place which says if you have for
example i don't know a a uh a country
which says you know
one child per family clearly that's
going to uh that whatever traits existed
in that population there'll be fewer of
them going forward if you have a
a uh
a group you know some some cultural
group that says have as many children as
possible
that will whatever traits existed in
that
in that cultural group will tend they'll
tend to be more of those in the future
because there were more children and
that's kind of uh so it's kind of this
notion of kind of choice of of uh
the the the the level of kind of choice
of more children less children and that
will determine how many of those traits
exist in the population going forward
so there are other there are other
effects as well like for example
there are plenty of
diseases
that you know would have killed us
earlier in life so to speak had it not
been for modern medicine
and it's its life expectancies have been
getting progressively longer
particularly not not the the maximum
sort of extension of life
has not changed that much but the
fraction of people who reach kind of
close to the maximum that's gotten much
much larger as a result of medicine many
of the kind of bugs that we know can
develop
uh medicine has allowed us to fix and so
that means that there are things which
in the past would have meant
that
um
you know that human wasn't going to make
it wasn't going to make it to have
children for example
now modern medicine lets them make it
and so whatever trait it was that would
have prevented them from making it to
have children that trait in the past
would have died off in the population
because they would have those those
people wouldn't have made it to the to
the point where they have children um
but now they can and so that means that
trait can survive in the population
where it wouldn't have been able to in
the past
and
you see and and different um so that
that's a that's an effect another effect
is the kind of socio-political forces
that determine you know who chooses to
have more children who doesn't you know
a very common issue is sort of the
economics of having children there are
places where it's just really expensive
to have children in a sense that you
know you have to take care of the
children and they cost a lot and if
you're going to have them sort of um be
educationally competitive they you spend
even more et cetera et cetera et cetera
and so that's for some people that's
kind of a socio-political disincentive
to to have more children and you know in
us in a sense the the natural selection
view of the of the population and
there's really no way around it i mean
if you if you have if there are more
children with certain traits then those
traits will be more common in the
population that's a
that's just a a necessary piece of of
the picture
so
you know at times in the past
people have had uh terrible ideas about
about you know right now we think this
type of human is is worse than that
other type of human and that's something
that was unfortunately a a sort of bad
consequence of the natural selection
theory um
the uh um
that um uh that was kind of like okay
now we understand how things work let's
control the course of biological
evolution disastrous idea i mean this
was what led to all sorts of terrible
things particularly in the early part of
the 20th century uh often around the the
word eugenics sort of uh which is from
greek it's sort of the the good race
type thing and it just it was uh it's in
the category of of uh one of the one of
the worst kind of consequences of of
sort of uh taking a view of science
and kind of saying let's just build
society around this as as it turns out
rather a shallow view of of what the
science implies
so i think that um uh but in
it's it's an interesting question
whether we can see you know the traits
that lead to people having more children
how are they correlated with other kinds
of traits
another thing that's true is
is the extent to which
uh you know for us humans where we have
you know two parents per child give or
take um the uh except for weird
technology technological approaches but
it's basically uh two parents per child
the the footnote there is that the
mitochondria which are which are in a
sense separate parts of our cells could
in principle come from another
another parent if you if you sort of
prepare the um uh the if you if you do
things kind of in a lab but normally
it's two parents per child and um there
are other complicated evolutionary
effects like for example there are
questions like uh oh i don't know like
for example how much
uh
are the how much
you know if you have sort of the most
deficient pairing of humans and and sort
of humans pair off in a way where
they're optimally suited for each other
how does that affect what the what the
progeny are like versus humans who are
uh you know very different who who have
children and so on how does that affect
what the um uh what the what the future
progeny uh are like and that's uh those
are those are more detailed effects then
there are other effects like at what age
of people had to having children that
you might think that's irrelevant but
there are things where okay so so much
of what's passed down from parent to
child is just purely genetics and it's
kind of randomly selected from the
mother father you know half from each
that that gets passed down to each child
but there are some other effects i mean
there there are uh
it was sort of a discredited view of
biological evolution
that sort of things that happened during
the lifetime of the parent
could have a direct biological effect i
mean they can have an effect of things
the parent learnt they could pass on as
matters of knowledge to their children
but things that have biologically
happened to the parent could they pass
them on and it became clear that things
like various kinds of deficiencies uh to
do with bad uh you know bad access to
various kinds of foods and so on those
could be passed on and uh and that's so
that's a place where again there's sort
of a modification to a footnote to the
whole darwinian story um that uh uh that
happens there but i think it's a it's a
um
um
it's a it's a it's a good question um
what uh
um
you know are we are we descending
towards the extinction
was asked um
well i don't think so i mean the
population of the earth is is i think
the it's often hard to project what the
population of the earth is going to do
and there are many countries where you
can see you know populations going up
dramatically but where demographic
estimates show that it will turn over
sometimes those are accurate sometimes
they are not um it often will depend on
on policies and other things and and
prosperity and so on in those countries
but i think the the general belief is
that the population of the world will
continue going up although maybe it will
turn over i mean a general fact about
sort of a geopolitical fact
is that in a first approximation the
more prosperous countries have lower
birth rates but that's not completely
true it's not true in all cultural
groups within those countries it's a not
a general uh idea um but it it it can be
true and that's partly for economic
reasons sometimes that people
uh you know if you're operating a family
farm
and you know children are a really good
source of labor for a family farm and
that's the reason in the u.s for example
where why people 100 you know a bit more
than 100 years ago when the u.s was a
largely agricultural agrarian society
why there were i think um you know it
was very typical for there to be very
large families uh who then uh would be
you know help help in the farm type
thing um and that's uh in the kind of
modern urban lifestyle it's a bit of a
different story um of uh you know the
children are expensive and they don't
fit in the apartment and and so on so
it's a different different set of
motivations um but i think that the um
uh the kind of um
uh
you know will there come a time
when um
uh
uh when sort of the population i mean
the the the certain uh
in you know clearly there are sort of
cultural forces at work of some kinds of
uh cultural prejudices or whatever tend
to lead to lower birth rates in some in
some cultural populations higher birth
rates in others and so that uh
that will tend to tip the balance of
those different kinds of things going
forward and
and time but i don't think we're at risk
of extinction for for those kinds of
reasons
uh
let's see talking of extinction we have
a question from d0 here how likely is it
for a big asteroid to hit the earth
not very
seems to happen about every 100 million
years maybe
maybe every 50 million years that's a
long time
um you know it's happened a few times
probably in the history of the earth in
the 4.6 billion years the earth has been
around the last really spectacular
uh one i i guess you could call it
spectacular after the fact was 65
million years ago
uh in the uh uh gulf of mexico the
the asteroid that uh
uh hit and it's becoming fairly clear
that there are some fossils that were
formed the very afternoon
that the asteroid hit the earth
of of dinosaurs that were covered in in
um i guess some kind of ash from the um
uh from uh of pulverized rock from the
impact and so on i mean that was a
dramatic moment i guess that was you
know produce these huge tidal waves
produced at that time uh dramatically
this kind of um
this this
generated a lot of um small
particles that ended up a small small
dust basically that ended up going into
the upper atmosphere of the earth
and that basically blocked out the sun
for a couple of years
and if you're a dinosaur without uh
without good hvac and good you know
heating and so on it's a bad thing and
to be you know a dinosaur who really
enjoyed the the um 70 degree fahrenheit
um uh weather to be plunged into
something at 30 degrees fahrenheit it's
it's not a good way to spend a couple of
years and that was a bad thing for the
dinosaurs i think there's pretty good
evidence that the dinosaurs were on
their way out anyway at that time but
that was kind of probably the the final
thing that sort of pushed them over the
edge towards extinction um and there
were no doubt other other features i
mean when you when you knock the earth
with an asteroid of that size it it has
all kinds of consequences probably for
things to do with volcanoes and all
kinds of other things um
that uh
and the tidal wave the tsunami that the
thing produced probably went a large
part of the way across the u.s and all
kinds of things like this
so kind of a messy situation now
in uh is that about to happen don't
think so wouldn't worry about it and
actually we know it's not going to
happen we know it's not going to happen
probably in the lifetime of anybody
alive today assuming that human
lifespans don't expand absolutely
dramatically because we can track every
asteroid and we can everything of of
that size and it's it's uh i don't think
there are any that are believed to be i
think there was one in um
50 40 50 years time or something that
looked like it might be on a collision
course for earth but don't think it is
so i think these these sort of big
asteroid impacts you know a long time in
advance that's one of the one of the
things that comes from understanding
physics and understanding laws of
gravity and so on so long as you can
detect these kinds of uh asteroids which
you can uh with telescopes and so on you
can
you can see what's coming now the big
question is what would you do about it
let's say there is a big asteroid
heading for the earth what do we do
well clearly i mean there's lots of
science fiction movie treatments of what
to do in that situation
uh the the likelihood is that you can
nudge the asteroid because you so long
as you reach it a long time before it's
actually going to hit the earth you
don't have to nudge it very much just a
tiny nudge tiny change of angle tiny
change of trajectory i think it's going
to miss the earth maybe it'll it will be
kind of uh if you if you do the science
correctly having it graze the upper
atmosphere and produce this amazing
light show might be something people
would like although maybe it's not the
best thing to you know it's it's kind of
living dangerously to do that but i
think that the um uh it's it's it's
likely to be possible how you would do
it
not completely clear i mean people talk
about nuclear explosions people talk
about uh
kind of
putting
things like just having progressive uh
uh
uh if it's if it has uh ice
for example water ice for instance
progressively heating up pieces of it so
it starts um spewing out steam which
will push it slightly and
and i think there's some schemes of
radiation pressure with them with
putting sort of uh solar with mirrors
essentially on the thing to gradually
use the the um uh the pressure of light
to deflect it those kinds of things
so
that's um uh that that's that's the
story of that i think that um
uh
people
um
i know a couple of people who are
involved in the kind of asteroid defense
business both at the level of uh
having contracts with the us government
to like provide the spacecraft to uh to
also trying to examine just how common
are
uh
near-earth asteroids of the right size
and the question of how common they are
depends greatly on things like how much
light does an asteroid typically emit or
how how much does it reflect like for
for the moon for example the moon looks
pretty bright in the sky but if the moon
was a mirror it will be unbelievably
brighter than it actually is the moon is
actually quite uh doesn't reflect much
of the light that falls on i think it's
like like a tenth of the light or
something is um is what is reflected by
moon rock
um from and the rest of it is just
absorbed uh of light from the sun the
albedo of the earth that's the the
albedo is the is the ratio of the amount
of light uh reflected to the amount of
light received the albedo of the earth
is a is an important thing to know and
it depends a lot on whether there are
clouds and things like that or whether
it's just you know a view of the ocean
or something the albedo of the earth is
important in determining how much the
earth heats up from the light of the sun
because if you're just reflecting all of
that light back into space you're not it
isn't absorbed and you don't get the
heat from from that and that's something
where one of the ways that one can
imagine doing for example geoengineering
if you say the earth's getting too hot
we want to cool it down how can we do
that well we can do something a little
bit like what happened to the dinosaurs
that is we can put some kind of uh you
know dust-like stuff in the upper
atmosphere of the earth which will
reflect light prevent more prevent as
much of it reaching the surface and
reduce the temperature of the surface
it's a difficult decision to say let's
go put
little
aerosols in the upper atmosphere um and
uh you know and cool the earth down
because it's something you don't get to
say we'll just cool down
uh you know the you will just cool down
kansas or something once you do that
you're cooling down the whole earth and
the um and that's something which sort
of everybody one imagines would have to
sort of agree that that's a good thing
to do and it's also the case that once
you've done it it's kind of like are you
did you really think through the
consequences of this you know as you
start growing the glaciers or whatever
happens as you cool the earth down is
that is that okay or is that is there
some glacier going to overtake some some
town somewhere or is it going to prevent
ships getting through this or that place
you know what really are the
consequences and it's it's usually very
hard to work out the consequences of
something like that
let's see
well as a question
a little bit complicated
um
let's see
there's a question here about from n
asking how far ahead can you talk about
human evolution adapting with
technological progression
um
i this is kind of we're continuing our
theme for a little bit earlier about
human evolution
um i think
the question of the the sort of
interweaving of technology with human
evolution
there are one there are pieces of that
that are kind of part of the the obvious
biological story of you know life
expectancies get longer people who would
otherwise not be able to have children
are able to have children because of
medical advances these kinds of things
um there are also
other aspects of sort of technology that
change
the
the landscape of what of where humans i
don't know where humans can live
what uh
another thing that's important is is uh
education the fact that
i mean one of the things that's sort of
a great uh invention of our species is
the ability it seems uniquely to pass on
abstract knowledge from one generation
to the next
i mean there are other species that have
ways to kind of show some stuff like
here's how to fly or something or maybe
they show that it's not clear they show
that or here's how to uh
uh you know the the maybe some some some
aspects of sort of behavior can be
passed on sort of generation to
generation by education but but we
humans with human language and with the
things that we've learned about how to
do education we are kind of the
so far as we know the unique example
where you can really pass on knowledge
and one feature of passing on knowledge
that really affects the evolution is the
following
if you
are a critter that has this idea that
you're going to i don't know
uh
uh catch your prey by setting traps
doing this or that thing
and um oh no you're going to you're
going to lay your eggs
in a particular
way on on beaches or whatever else
and then something changes in the world
and you can't do that anymore well you
are genetically programmed to do that
and that's kind of all you know and
every success of generation just it's
got that same genetic programming
gradually over the course of many
generations maybe
the the thing that randomly mutated to
have genetics that caused it to say
actually we can lay our eggs in a tree
or something instead um the uh that that
uh will be the one that wins out but if
you have knowledge if you have education
it's like one speech one generation
discovers no no you don't have to you
don't dig out the sand to put your eggs
you can just put them in a tree um and
then you say let me just tell my
children that's what to do and educate
the next generation that's an incredibly
much faster way to to make those changes
and that allows adaptation to the things
that happen in the world or you know
this is the this is the amazing way to
be more successful
in in uh living in the world and
progressively having more children etc
etc etc um this is the way to do that
and i think that that's um you know
that's a way in which in a sense
education
uh which in some ways relies on
technology it relies on things like
writing it relies on nowadays on
communications and so on um that makes
makes those kinds of things possible i
mean it's also worth realizing that
there are aspects of evolution that
operate not just on the biology of
humans but also on the ideas that humans
think about i mean this kind of notion
of memes as well as genes
memes was originally kind of the idea of
sort of elements of thought not
necessarily you know slogans on on on
you know instagram posts or whatever
that were um uh
that were things where it's an idea you
know the idea of arranging society with
democracy or the idea
of doing this or that thing of having um
uh you know these or the idea of doing
science or something these ideas are
things that have a sort of natural
selection of their own in the sense that
they if if nobody likes them they sort
of eventually die out if one person
likes them and passes it on to more
people
then they gradually get more more
prevalent in the population
and uh that process is a is a
complicated and sometimes frustrating
process to watch because it's not always
the case this is probably the case in
biological evolution the best species
don't always win uh whatever best means
um but uh that's something which sort of
affects evolution is this evolution of
ideas as well as evolution of the
biology of of humans and i think
obviously the the uh you know one
critical aspect of evolution is the
basic rhythm of evolution is there's one
generation it has children the children
have children etc and the previous
generation dies off
and that is the phenomenon that's
happened throughout biological time
and
the question is if there comes a point
at which in human evolution that no
longer happens either because we sort of
solve the biological problems
of uh effective immortality or because
we decide to sort of go digital and
decide that our existence is better in
kind of the uh the virtual world so to
speak and and all of our sort of future
history is is played out in a virtual
environment um if if those things happen
then that will dramatically change kind
of what has been the the rhythm of human
evolution and i think it's also the
rhythm to some extent of human
uh of lots of things about human life is
kind of like there's a limited lifespan
and this will happen and that will
happen and so on and so there's a set of
things that that people have the
objective of doing um and but that's
it's a different story if you're kind of
if the biological or digital you is kind
of like well i'm going to be around in a
million years
let's um uh you know let me decide what
to do today i've got uh another
300 million of these days to run so to
speak uh it kind of changes the
perspective i think a bit um on uh uh on
what what to do i mean certainly
something one sees in in human sort of
society and cultural situations there
are some cultures where people are very
uh sort of uh concerned with this kind
of longevity of progression of you know
we've been doing this for 500 years type
thing we've been carrying on this
tradition for 500 years and other places
where people are like what we're doing
now that's what we're doing i don't
really care what the last generation did
how it happened in the past it's a
different kind of rhythm of activity and
i suppose that's a place where one can
see sort of a model of what happens in
the case of uh of sort of effective
immortality of of how that will play out
and uh you know from some point of view
it might be like oh if you've got an
infinite time to do things you won't get
anything done today maybe or maybe it's
uh that means it's worth building for
the future because you'll be around to
witness that future hard to tell
all right maybe uh one more here
um
okay there's a question from eggy here
we're on the evolution thing could gene
drive technology replace natural
evolution in favor of intelligent design
yeah well okay so the basic point there
is that with gene editing
there is um a
as a result of discoveries made in the
last what is it 10 15 years
it's possible to basically target a
piece of a genome including a human
genome and say just edit this piece of
the genome whenever you see certain
sequences on the genome that look like
this go splice out the piece in the
middle and update it and change it to
this
and so that's a way of changing uh
and the thing which is interesting about
that is it changes
not only if you change
the uh
uh
the the the if if you
sort of make that change
and the organism reproduces and you made
that change in the in the line of cells
that will will be reproduced then you've
changed that species permanently it's
not just you change that particular
organism you change all the children of
that organism and and so on uh sort of
forever
um
and uh
uh okay this might be my reminder that
um to um uh
to wrap up here
um
but uh oh perhaps not no i think that's
some um okay in any case um
the uh
uh
so the the idea is for example one place
where people have talked about this
when there are mosquitoes that give
nasty diseases diseases like malaria
particularly in africa there's kind of
this idea hey why don't we just modify
the mosquitoes just put
a new genetic setup for mosquitoes and
sort of push it through that population
and just
change the mosquitoes so they can't
carry malaria and they're harmless and
and it's all good so to speak
um
that's a you know it's a little bit like
put aerosols in the upper atmosphere of
the earth it's kind of a hard decision
to make because once you launch that
it's kind of hard to to pull back from
it it's kind of a thing that's going to
spread through this population and you
know one has to it's very hard to know
what consequences it has and i think
there's a certain degree of of kind of
uh just how sure are we of the science
and technology and so on um and uh uh
you know at what point are we sure
enough that we want to make one of these
global changes i mean i think the the
the life of this pandemic that we've all
been experiencing is perhaps not the
best example of we really know
everything about what the science and
consequences of different kinds of
things are going to be it's it's been a
story of many kinds of places where
where it's clear as one could have
predicted and i i certainly was aware of
some of this that uh you know things
weren't going to go quite as
as the most obvious science would
predict and so it's it's a it's a
difficult thing to decide to make those
changes i think that um uh there are
other cases like well that there are uh
so but but that you know that's a place
where you could decide yes we're going
to change the human population
or change the mosquito population or
change the human population and one
certainly wonders whether in in the
future there'll be kind of this fashion
you know people will say i really want
my children to have green eyes okay
great we can modify that gene and uh you
know children will have green eyes or i
really want this or that trait and and
that could go horribly wrong because it
could be the case that say
you know for example everybody wants a
child who will act like a leader and
then the whole world is full of people
who want to act like leaders this might
not end well um i mean it's uh or you
know some other trait that um
that that might be good in one case but
uh might not play well either for the
whole population or even just turn out
to play well in the end or somebody says
i think i really want my kid to be to
have this or that characteristic because
it's in fashion right now i mean it's
it's like if you look at at uh first
names of of kids there are tremendous
waves of of uh of sort of fashion for
different names i mean i think uh my
parents always claimed that they've been
innovative with my first name which
which uh kind of the data shows was
definitely not the case stephen was a
pretty common name uh when i was born
maybe not as common in england as in the
us one of the things that always charms
me about this is there's a immortal
alpha if you type in a first name
uh because it knows the uh the the
frequencies of different names over the
course of time it can predict for you
what the most likely age of a person
with that name is and it really does
remarkably well remarkably often because
they've been these big waves of
popularity for different names one thing
that always charms me is that i think
steven was a particularly common name in
in the us
about so i don't know
60 to 65 to 75 years ago and so
people and and everybody who was called
stephen at that time got nicknamed steve
and so for me it's it's just a dead
giveaway that if somebody calls me steve
which is not what people usually call me
um they're sort of guaranteed american
over the age of 60. that's uh then
they'll call me steve and they'll do so
pretty much 100 of the time um and that
was sort of a sign of the of the stephen
bump or something or the steve bump uh
that existed at that time that was sort
of a fashion and first names that's a
place where people pick something about
a kid and it sort of survives over the
course of the life of that kid unless
they choose to change their name and
often you see these kind of secondary
bumps of a name that was popular at one
time and and then it'll be somebody's
grandparents name and and so they'll
name the kid after that and you see
these kind of echoes of of different
name popularities well the same thing
might happen with biological traits it'd
be rather weird
of this oh well you are you know you're
40 years old so you probably have green
eyes because um uh that was popular at
that time in in sort of uh the history
of things being developed i mean i i you
know i i tend to think these things are
uh are probably in the category of not a
good idea unintended consequences that
are bad um but uh on the other hand um
uh you know science can achieve some
things and so one has to one has to kind
of uh one has to sort of balance those
different uh
possibilities
all right well i think we should wrap up
for now today um but uh
i thank you for lots of interesting
questions i see there are many more that
i didn't have a chance to get to here
and um
i think uh uh look forward to doing this
again i'm not sure if next week we'll
hit a day where i'll be able to do it
but um
certainly within the next couple of
weeks we should be
doing this again
and um
otherwise
if
happy holidays to people if it's that
time of year for you
and